Rusia Rusia y más Rusia Así ha sido el
bombardeo de noticias internacionales
desde que las hordas de Putin invadieron
Ucrania en febrero de 2022 la Guerra de
Ucrania ha acaparado prácticamente toda
la atención mediática y política a nivel
internacional y Es lógico digamos que la
Guerra de Ucrania ha tapado lógicamente
todo lo demás incluyendo otros eventos
también trágicos por ejemplo recordáis
estas imágenes de 2021
efectivamente queridos amigos amigas en
agosto de 2021 con La retirada de las
últimas tropas de Estados Unidos
Afganistán volvió a caer en manos del
fundamentalismo islámico Afganistán cayó
otra vez en manos de los talibanes y ya
sé lo que muchos nos vais a decir pero
vamos a ver no nos contasteis ya toda
esta historia Pues sí es cierto en 2021
aquí en visualpoliti aplicamos una
trilogía para contaros Por qué los
talibanes tuvieron tanto éxito y qué
podría significar su regreso si no lo
visteis os dejamos los links abajo en la
descripción El caso es que prácticamente
dos años de gobierno talibán después
hemos querido preparar un nuevo vídeo
para contaros cómo está siendo el nuevo
gobierno Y qué ha supuesto exactamente
el regreso de los talibanes al poder
aunque creo que con noticias como esta
ya sabéis por dónde van los tiros los
niños afganos mueren de hambre a medida
que el hambre se extiende rápidamente el
hambre y la pobreza siguen acechando a
los desesperados afganos la falta de
financiación golpea la maltrecha
economía afgana provocando Un aumento de
la pobreza efectivamente Afganistán está
pasando por una de sus peores crisis de
todos los tiempos y la ayuda humanitaria
pues Simplemente ya no llega como
ocurría antes de los talibanes pero no
sólo eso la destrucción de Prácticamente
todo tipo de libertades individuales el
haber convertido a este país de nuevo en
un refugio de grupos radicales su
particular forma de gobernar despótica y
anacrónica están haciendo que Afganistán
dispute la competición por convertirse
en el peor país del mundo pero queridos
amigos amigas cómo han llegado los
talibanes hasta aquí de qué forma están
gobernando exactamente Afganistán están
siendo el gobierno tan desastroso como
muchos señalan o por contra están
Aprendiendo a llevar las riendas del
país Quiénes están cortejando hoy a los
talibanes Pues bien en este vídeo os
vamos a responder a todas estas
preguntas y ya os adelanto que muchas
respuestas seguro que os van a
sorprender o quizás no tanto arranquemos
[Música]
seguro que muchos si no la gran mayoría
pensaréis que los talibanes no son más
que una panda de zumbados con ansias de
poder y en cierto modo puede que así sea
pero sabéis de dónde salieron o suena de
algo la palabra muljaidin Pues los
talibanes comenzaron siendo muyahines es
decir en términos estrictos combatientes
islamistas que hacen la yihad sin
embargo normalmente cuando nos hablan de
mullaidines muchos automáticamente
seguro que pensamos En aquellos afganos
apoyados por Estados Unidos que lucharon
contra la unión soviética cuando ésta
invadió Afganistán en 1979 Claro que
después de La retirada soviética los
muyaitines hicieron estallar una especie
de guerra civil entre el 92 y el 96 de
ese conflicto nacieron los talibanes
quienes Por cierto ganaron la guerra y
así queridos amigos nació en 1996 el
primer gobierno talibán
el primer gobierno talibán ha sido
considerado como uno de los más brutales
de la historia reciente los Derechos
Humanos eran constantemente pisoteados
ejecuciones públicas en campos de fútbol
lapidación de mujeres por adulterio y
castigos inhumanos por simplemente
Mostrar alguna mínima parte del cuerpo
femenino por supuesto cualquier derecho
o libertad individual para las mujeres
fue borrado completamente del mapa se
las privó de la educación de tener un
empleo incluso de poder desplazarse si
no era con un hombre de su círculo todo
un infierno el régimen era tan brutal
que solamente era reconocido por tres
países en todo el mundo Pakistán Arabia
saudí los emiratos árabes Unidos el
régimen terminó cayendo cinco años
después de hacerse con el poder Claro
que no cayó por ninguna revuelta social
sino por la intervención del Tío Sam
como todos sabéis tras los atentados del
11s Estados Unidos puso en su mirada a
los talibanes por haber hecho en un
espacio seguro para grupos terroristas
como la al qaeda de Bin Laden Washington
exigió entonces la entrega de los
líderes de al qaeda y como los talibanes
se negaron en octubre de ese mismo año
las tropas norteamericanas invadieron el
país el primer gobierno talibán era
historia
sin embargo como decimos en España
hierba mala nunca muere y eso es
exactamente lo que pasó con los
talibanes a pesar del control aplastante
de Estados Unidos Durante los primeros
años en 2005 los talibanes comenzaron a
reagruparse y en 2006 Ya empezaron a
desarrollar operaciones de cierta
envergadura contra las tropas
estadounidenses
a partir de entonces y con el apoyo del
gobierno de Pakistán poco a poco la
presencia y la influencia de los
talibanes se fue extendiendo por la
mayor parte del país además gracias a
los altos ingresos derivados del
comercio del opio los talibanes lograron
convertirse en la insurgencia mejor
financiada armada y organizada En
definitiva la insurgencia perfecta y
toda una pesadilla para Washington la
férrea resistencia talibán y los escasos
avances tanto del gobierno como de los
propios militares afganos hicieron que
el entonces presidente Donald Trump
tomara una decisión que copó todos los
titulares internacionales en 2020 fijaos
conflicto afgano Estados Unidos y los
talibanes firman un acuerdo para poner
fin a 18 años de guerra efectivamente
sin la participación del gobierno de
Afganistán Trump llegó a un acuerdo con
los talibanes prometió retirar todas las
tropas de Estados Unidos para el verano
de 2021 a cambio los talibanes debían
comprometerse a que Afganistán no se en
un nido de grupos terroristas
internacionales que pudieran amenazar a
Estados Unidos y sus aliados el segundo
gobierno talibán en Afganistán estaba ya
en marcha y amigos eso es exactamente lo
que ocurrió en 2021 de forma mucho más
rápida de lo que nadie hubiera previsto
tras la salida de las tropas
norteamericanas el ejército afgano
prácticamente se deshizo y los talibanes
volvieron a tomar kabul desde entonces
este país desapareció de los grandes
medios de comunicación Pero qué ha
ocurrido desde entonces cómo es el nuevo
Afganistán de los talibanes Pues bien
veámoslo
talibanes versión actualizada
[Música]
seamos honestos cualquiera con dos dedos
de frente sabía que los talibanes iban a
seguir un recorrido más o menos similar
al de su primer gobierno Es cierto que
esta vez se han intentado Mostrar como
algo más moderados pero los datos son
los datos y la realidad es que este
Afganistán talibán se ha convertido
nuevamente en un infierno en la tierra
Aunque para unos más que para otros
Afganistán los talibanes prohíben el
acceso de las mujeres a las
universidades en medio de la condena
internacional los talibanes prohíben a
las mujeres afanas trabajar con Naciones
Unidas Exacto querida comunidad de
visualpolitik los talibanes han hecho
justo lo que todos esperábamos se han
vuelto a cargar de un plumazo
prácticamente todos los derechos y
libertades de las mujeres no pueden
estudiar en las universidades ni las
adolescentes en los institutos tampoco
pueden trabajar en ongs ni en las
agencias de Naciones Unidas Y no sólo
eso en las empresas en las que tengan
permitido trabajar que cada vez son
menos sólo pueden hacerlo si están
completamente separadas de los hombres y
por supuesto si no cumplen con el
estricto código de vestimenta pueden
esperarse lo peor todo ello por cortesía
del restablecido Ministerio de la
propagación de la virtud y la prevención
del vicio que es el que los talibanes
han puesto en sustitución del Ministerio
de la mujer que había hasta su llegada y
ahí No termina todo
junto a las mujeres los tallicos que son
las voces más críticas con los talibanes
y el segundo grupo étnico más grande del
país después de los pastunes a los
cuales Por cierto pertenecen la mayoría
de los talibanes también están siendo
duramente reprimidos redadas
allanamientos detenciones arbitrarias
palizas desapariciones además de
asesinatos extrajudiciales han plagado
de miedo a los tacos y prácticamente a
cualquiera que se atreva a criticar al
régimen talibán por supuesto como os
podéis imaginar la libertad de expresión
brilla por su ausencia pero no solo eso
recordáis el trato de Trump con los
talibanes Sí eso de que no convertirían
Afganistán otra vez en un nido de
terroristas pues vosotros mismos según
un experto Afganistán vuelve a ser Un
refugio para los terroristas ya que la
capacidad de Estados Unidos sobre el
Horizonte se enfrenta a limitaciones
efectivamente queridos amigos de
visualpolitik grupos como al qaeda o los
talibanes pakistan conocidos Como el ttp
ahora campan a sus anchas por todo el
país de hecho sabéis dónde fue asesinado
el líder real
alza guajiri en el verano del 2022 pues
ni más ni menos que en el mismísimo
centro de kabul la capital afgana 2 de
Agosto 2022 muere el líder del qaeda y
Manuel jaguagiri Estados Unidos afirma
que un ataque con drones de la Cia ha
matado al líder de al qaeda y manos a
guajira en kabul la capital de
Afganistán en el mayor golpe al grupo
desde la muerte de su fundador osamabil
Laden en el año 2011 Aunque bueno Es
cierto que los talibanes al menos Sí
están combatiendo al estado islámico de
jora-san la organización que atentó en
el aeropuerto de kabul cuando las tropas
de Estados Unidos estaban retirando y
que acabó con la vida de una docena de
soldados americanos y 150 afganos pero
seamos realistas este enfrentamiento no
tiene nada que ver con el acuerdo con
Trump sino con las hostilidades que
existen entre ambos grupos vamos toda
una lucha de poder sin embargo pese a
todas las atrocidades muchos analistas
también dicen estar muy sorprendidos con
algunos aspectos de la gestión económica
de los talibanes
después de choque económico inicial los
talibanes han conseguido manejar y
estabilizar la economía del país por
ejemplo han conseguido recuperar en
cierto modo el valor que la moneda
nacional el affani tenía antes del
aislamiento internacional mediante un
control más férreo de los dólares que
salen del país además según el Banco
Mundial la corrupción y las aduanas ha
caído de un 62% a un 8 debido sobre todo
a los graves castigos que las haría o la
islámica impone roba y te cortamos una
mano también han conseguido los ingresos
suficientes como para poder pagarle el
sueldo a los 800.000 empleados públicos
del país entre ellos a 150.000 soldados
y 200.000 policías
Incluso se están permitiendo el lujo de
poner en marcha algunos proyectos
grandes los talibanes están cavando un
enorme canal un mega proyecto en el
norte de Afganistán corre el riesgo de
aumentar las tensiones regionales por
supuesto todo esto no son más que
apuntes en el margen pensáis que la
situación del país permite ser
optimistas pues como os podéis imaginar
nada más lejos de la realidad
después de que los talibanes llegan al
poder el país quedó totalmente aislado
además de sufrir un montón de sanciones
entre 2021 y 2022 la economía cayó un
35%. llevándose por delante cientos de
miles de empleos y destruyendo la mayor
parte del Pequeño tejido productivo del
país esto como no sorprenderá estar
llevando al límite a la sociedad afgana
según la ONU en 97% de la población vive
en pobreza y el número de afganos que
necesitan ayuda humanitaria ha pasado de
unos 6 millones en 2019 a 28 millones en
la actualidad esto ha hecho que la
hambruna se esté apoderando rápidamente
de Afganistán y eso a pesar de la ayuda
humanitaria enviada por la ONU Estados
Unidos la Unión Europea y otros actores
internacionales y claro con semejante
panorama no resulta extraño que los
talibanes estén buscando rápidamente una
solución lo que pasa primero por
intentar ser reconocidos a nivel
internacional para así poder conseguir
cierta estabilidad y normalidad pero
creéis que hay algún estado que lo
quiera reconocer Pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
el reconocimiento el gran reto talibán
ya os hemos contado que en los años 90
solo 3 países reconocieron al gobierno
talibán Pues bien sabéis Cuántos países
les han reconocido en este segundo
periodo la cantidad total de cero cero
países efectivamente querida comunidad
de visualpolitik Esta vez ni la propia
Pakistán les ha querido reconocer por
ahora y eso que los han estado apoyando
casi desde su nacimiento Pero esta vez
las cosas son diferentes cerca de dos
años después de Regresar al poder ni sus
socios más cercanos confían en ellos por
ejemplo cojamos el caso de Pakistán
Pakistán tiene varios problemas con este
Afganistán talibán Empezando por el
apoyo que la India les está brindando lo
que lógicamente no está sentando nada
bien en islamabad con todo probablemente
es el conflicto fronterizo por la
denominada línea Durant lo que más
tensiones está generando entre ambos
países esta línea que es la que separa a
los dos países fue establecida por el
Imperio británico en 1893 y desde la
independencia de ambos países ha sido
una constante fuente de tensión de hecho
los enfrentamientos entre las tropas
fronterizas de ambos países no son algo
nada extraño sin embargo parece que las
cosas se están calmando 8 de mayo de
2023 acuerdan impulsar el comercio y
rebajar las tensiones fronterizas Claro
que no vayamos tan rápido hay un asunto
que no solo es un impedimento para que
Pakistán reconozca a los talibanes sino
que también lo es para dos de los
actores regionales y mundiales más
importantes China y Rusia
[Música]
ya sea Pakistán China o Rusia los tres
países tienen algo en común su
preocupación por la seguridad nacional y
regional en este sentido Por ejemplo
Pakistán acusado a los talibanes afganos
de darles un espacio seguro a los
talibanes pakistaníes quienes rompieron
el alto el fuego con el gobierno
pakistaní el 28 de noviembre del 2022 y
que ya han atentado en ciudades
importantes del país como pesaguar o
karachi matando a docenas de personas
por su lado China tiene una preocupación
bastante similar pero en este caso con
el movimiento islámico del turquestán
Oriental y está formado por
fundamentalistas islámicos de la etnia
que concentra su actividad en la región
Autónoma de chillán que precisamente
hace frontera con Afganistán de esta
forma china teme que los talibanes hagan
de su país una especie de espacio seguro
para los militantes ohigures y por eso
exige que kabul siga entregando a los
que capture como ya venía haciendo el
anterior gobierno afgano sin embargo los
talibanes ya han dejado libres a varios
de ellos lo que en Pekín no ha sentado
demasiado bien
en este sentido Rusia es el país menos
preocupado de los tres ya que su mayor
amenaza el estado islámico del jorasan o
Isis K que ha comenzado una campaña anti
Rusia está siendo combatido por los
talibanes en suelo afgano sin embargo ni
la propia Rusia ha reconocido aún a los
talibanes como los legítimos gobernantes
de Afganistán Claro que eso no significa
que no se haya acercado ya a ellos
[Música]
de hecho Rusia ha sido el primer estado
encerrar un acuerdo de esta magnitud con
los talibanes los talibanes iban a un
acuerdo con Rusia para vender petróleo
gas y trigo a bajo precio y lo cierto Es
que china tampoco se está quedando atrás
ha levantado el 98% de los aranceles
para los productos afganos ya comenzado
a dar visados a empresarios de este país
y no sólo eso a pesar de las escasas
infraestructuras que hay en Afganistán
el año pasado también aprobó una
inversión de 216 millones de dólares
para construir un parque industrial a
las afueras de kabul además qué queréis
que os diga que china Rusia o Pakistán
terminarán reconociendo al gobierno
talibán no sería ninguna sorpresa
digamos que no suelen llevarse muy bien
con las normas impuestas por occidente y
por eso ya han dado algunos pasos en esa
dirección la de reconocer a los
talibanes Claro que sin garantías de
seguridad y cooperación creíbles esto
también está en el aire y lo cierto Es
que tampoco cambiaría gran cosa
lo diferente sería que Estados Unidos o
la Unión Europea lo reconociera y lo
queráis o no muchos analistas americanos
ya lo están pidiendo la razón pues la de
siempre podéis influir Hasta cierto
punto en la deriva del gobierno talibán
y del país Estados Unidos debería
reconocer diplomáticamente al gobierno
talibán de Afganistán no es fácil para
mí decirlo como ex embajadorafano
hacerlo será percibido como una dolorosa
traición para muchos pero la alternativa
permitir el peligroso descenso de
Afganistán a un reino ermitaño y
renunciar a las perspicacia y a los
medios para influir en los
acontecimientos serían consecuencias más
nefastas para todos al igual que este
embajador muchos analistas creen que ni
las sanciones ni ninguna otra forma de
coerción va a hacer que los talibanes
cedan en su empeño de seguir violando
los derechos humanos y que lo mejor que
puede hacer Estados Unidos en este
momento es reconocerlo antes que ningún
otro país para intentar hacer de
Afganistán un lugar menos hostil Este es
el debate
[Aplausos]
[Música]
en cualquier caso para hacerlo primero
Tendría que haber alguna certeza de que
los talibanes escucharan las
recomendaciones estadounidenses algo que
no nos engañemos parece muy improbable
de momento biden no ha dado señales de
que vaya a reconocer a los talibanes lo
que supone un duro golpe para una
Afganistán que está pasando por uno de
los peores momentos de su historia dicho
esto La pregunta es para todos vosotros
creéis que va y bien debería reconocer a
los talibanes podría hacerlo Trump si
volviera a la presidencia En 2024 cuál
creéis que será el primer estado en
reconocerlos será Rusia la primera para
formar una hermandad de Estados paria
quizás china podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios como
siempre no olvidéis Que aquí en
visualpolitik sacamos vídeos nuevos
Todas las semanas así que suscribíos a
este canal y dale a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si este vídeo os ha
resultado interesante hacérnoslo saber
dándole al botón de like como siempre
nos vemos en un próximo vídeo hasta
pronto
[Música]